it doesn't matter how big and strong you
are if you get injured you're gonna be
left vulnerable this is something that
gym goers know all too well if they've
ever been forced to take a week off of
their training or more
that's why recovering the body's ability
to repair itself after an injury or
illness are among the most important
aspects of our biology when it comes to
maximizing performance and also just not
feeling like [ __ ] our bodies are
constantly being degraded over time but
when everything is working properly
that only creates the opportunity for
them to come back better and more
resilient than before as nishan would
put it what doesn't kill you makes you
stronger so how can you support this
vital process and ensure that you're
coming back stronger how can you
Jubilate and restore your body quickly
and efficiently in order to be able to
perform your very best every day how can
you develop a Wolverine or Deadpool like
healing so that nothing can keep you
down for long I did some seriously deep
research into this one but please keep
in mind that I am NOT a doctor this is
just some cool stuff that I found it's
up to you to do more research so let's
dive in and see what options there are
what doesn't kill you make sure if you
want to understand how to aid our bodies
and healing us and it would first help
to understand how that process works
currently when we injure ourselves then
the body responds with a wound healing
cascade this has four stages clot
formation inflammation proliferation and
maturation the clot formation stage is
intended to stop bleeding and also
prevent infection from bacteria viruses
or fungi interestingly the
fight-or-flight response which is
triggered immediately following an
injury and often just before we're
actually helped to increase the
viscosity of the blood and contract
blood vessels to aid with the formation
of clots as necessary a clot also known
as a thrombus is formed by blood
coagulation and is made from platelets
and red blood cells to form a plug along
with a mesh of fiber and protein
this clotting is then followed by a
neutrophil invasion within minutes
following a trauma and which lasts for
24 to 48 hours these are white blood
cells created in the bone marrow which
of course have the job of preventing and
reversing infections neutrophils also
cause damage to the host tissue however
and this is thought to be one of the
reasons they're short-lived in duration
inflammation continues beyond this point
however with the role of infection
fighting being overtaken by longer
lasting macrophages and other agents
these cells will trigger the release of
growth hormone encouraging v and blasts
to travel to the area along with
epithelial and endothelial cells to
begin forming new capillaries and
support enhanced blood flow
next is proliferation during this stage
and immature granulation tissue is born
consisting of new connective tissue and
microscopic blood vessels this appears
on top of the skin produced by the
fibroblasts this tissue forms starting
at the edges of the injury and then
travels in was towards the center and
begins to form large amounts of type 3
collagen its creation is dependent on
the fibroblasts receiving a sufficient
amount of oxygen and nutrients via the
blood vessels meanwhile cells necessary
for regeneration and capillary growth
will divide and copy themselves via
mitosis as this tissue matures during
the maturation phase the fibroblast will
slow their production of collagen become
more spindly in appearance and produce
the stronger type one collagen rather
than the weaker but easier to produce
type 3 finally any new blood vessels are
no longer needed will be removed by
apoptosis cell death this process can
take an entire year in some cases okay
so that's an awful lot of information
but don't worry if you didn't take it
all in its just to provide a bit of
background what we're going to look at
next so what can we take from all this
the first thing is the inflammation
itself is not a bad thing in fact it's
now widely thought that using NS aids
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs to
reduce the pain of Dom's delayed onset
muscle soreness the muscle pain felt
after an intense workout may actually
impair hypertrophy this makes a lot of
sense when you consider that the
information leads to the production of
growth hormone and igf-1 and other
useful anabolic hormones likewise icing
information on wounds might inhibit
their recovery that might sound pretty
counterintuitive and it goes against
much of what we've been taught but
there's a lot of evidence to suggest
that this might be the case icing not
only slows down the recovery of wounds
but it also actually limits the extent
of the eventual recovery there are some
findings that show contradictory results
but keep in mind that reaching for the
ice pack might not be the first best
move elevating the limb is considered
okay and so is using compression
the aim instead is to encourage blood
flow to the affected area and there are
numerous ways you can do this that we'll
be getting into later now you might be
wondering about contrast therapy this is
the very trendy process of subjecting a
recovering athlete to both hot and cold
in an alternating fashion the idea is
that the hot water will cause
vasodilation widening the blood vessels
to allow more blood to flow to the
affected area while the cold water will
increase vasoconstriction narrowing the
blood vessels at the same time this will
also cause for the limp vessels to
expand the contract helping to pump
stagnant fluid away from the area this
is potentially beneficial seeing as the
lymph system doesn't have a pump
mechanism of its own that said there's
also possibility that this treatment
might inadvertently reduce the good type
of information as well and say more
research is needed before you can
definitely put this in the win column so
about improving blood flow one way we
can do this is through supplementation
in particular it turns out that the once
popular pre-workout supplement
l-arginine might actually be highly
beneficial for helping with healing
l-arginine as a vasodilator as well
meaning it opens up the blood vessels to
enhance blood flow to the wound area by
raising nitric oxide it might also be
able to increase the number of satellite
cells that can be used during
hypertrophy and other forms of tissue
repair but any vasodilator such as epic
a surgeon will also have these benefits
so more interesting is the fact that it
also seems to be able to increase the
amount of collagen that collects around
the wound this is effective both the
container swings and fractures for all
these reasons it seems that Argan iron
supplementation might be particularly
useful for recovery from numerous types
of injury our ganene supplementation is
most effective when taken at 2 percent
of energy and then UN energy and protein
requirements are met it should go
without saying that protein and carbs in
general are beneficial for healing
l-citrulline might actually be more
effective in wound healing just as it is
as a pre-workout due to it being a
precursor to our ganene there's actually
significantly more bioavailable that we
absorbed and used better by the body the
use of amino acids and other nutrients
in this way to enhance recovery falls
under the heading of immuno nutrition
this is a somewhat controversial though
very interesting field with other
popular supplements being bitumen C
which plays an important role in the
production of collagen and omega-3 fatty
acid in one study it was found that the
mice given vitamin C showed improved
wound contraction
time improved collagen deposition and
increased fiber blasting numbers another
study showed the bitumen C
supplementation could aid to the healing
of pressure sores in human participants
the role of omega-3 fatty acid on the
other hand is one that's still
interestingly up for debate omega-3 is
pretty much my favorite all-around
nutrient everyone has a favorite
nutrient right and make it three is
particularly lauded for its ability to
lower chronic inflammation it does this
by reducing the production of
pro-inflammatory cytokines while
lowering inflammation might be
beneficial in normal waking life it
could actually have a detrimental effect
of course during wound healing seeing as
we now know the importance of that
response indeed this is corroborated by
a number of studies but with that said
other studies suggest that omega-3 might
be useful in shortening recovery times
and lowering risk of infection in
particular combining arcanine
supplements with omega-3 appears to be
beneficial to wound healing across
multiple studies as possible that
omega-3 is beneficial to some aspects of
wound healing epithelium for instance
but detrimental to others such as
collagen deposition one option then is
to take a combination of omega-3 and
argonite together for the first couple
of days following injury and then to
reduce omega-3 intake for the latter
period it may also be that omega-3
somehow makes the healing process more
efficient thereby reducing swelling for
the right reasons however more research
needs to be carried out before official
directions can be ascertained other
nutrients that have been demonstrated to
support healing include vitamin A zinc
vitamin K antioxidants amino acids boron
might be useful in bone repair and
anything that raises testosterone and
growth hormone will help to place her in
a more anabolic State for enhanced
tissue recovery so with all that in mind
you might conceivably be able to conjure
up the kind of healing stack if you're
trying to recover from an injury you
also now know not to necessarily reach
for the ice pack right away what else
might help or one other important factor
is likely to be sleep while some studies
have failed to demonstrate a vital role
for sleep in healing more recent
findings have called that into doubt it
also stands to reason that sleep would
help with healing after all sleep is the
most anabolic state during which time we
see huge spikes in growth hormone during
sleep we also see an increase in cell
division and in another recent study
appeared that sleep was actually more
important than nutrition for recovery
in particular it seems that deep sleep
stages 3 & 4 are especially instrumental
in the recovery of wounds so anything
can do to boost the quality of your
sleeping to get more of it will also
encourage better healing general rest
and avoidance of psychological stress is
also probably a good idea psychological
stress increases the production of
cortisol and other stress hormones which
can blunt the repair processes for
instance if you were to injure yourself
whilst preparing for a stressful exam
you'd likely find that the wound was
slower to heal and it otherwise might be
countless studies show a link between
self-reported stress and delayed healing
and this is also true for muscle repair
stress it appears can actually impair
the initial inflammatory response and
reduce the production of cytokines which
presumably is an evolutionary mechanism
intended to allow us to escape the
dangerous situation before information
limits movement the role of stress learn
is to plug your wound to provide you
with enough energy to get out of danger
it's only once safe then that the body
will enter into a more relaxed state and
will begin to focus more on recovery
resting is also a good idea for a whole
host of different reasons when it comes
to recovery apart from anything else it
will prevent re-injury
and the formation of compensating
movement patterns it's why I now take a
whole week off of training once every
month or so I made a whole video
recently on the importance of recovering
training so be sure to check that out
hopefully you now have a fairly good
idea of how to support your body's
natural healing processes and perhaps
some things to avoid but if you really
want Wolverine s healing then you're
going to need some real transhuman
technology to take your body to the next
level and this is coming for instance we
know the importance of extracellular
matrix and might consider using a more
potent exogenously
this is exactly what some scientists
have been doing using the extracellular
matrix derived from some highly
regenerative pig bladders in order to
help heal a wider range of severe wounds
these pig guts provide the scaffolding
necessary for tissue repair and were
rare in the fact that they were able to
retain their basement membrane once
removed
in 2005 a 72 year old man accidentally
cut off his fingertip a few weeks later
after sprinkling a mysterious powder on
it sent to him by his brother his finger
grew back just the way it was before in
the near future he might also be able to
look forward to things like BPC one57
this is a peptide containing 15 amino
acids this derived from human gastric
juices it was originally synthesized to
help treat inflammatory bowel syndrome
and gastric ulcers but it has since been
shown to be useful in regenerating bones
muscles ligaments and more BPC one57
appears to help in increasing
angiogenesis the formation of new blood
vessels he also appears to promote
growth hormone production currently it's
not thought to have any side effects but
while the substance is already being
used by some risk-taking bodybuilders
keep in mind that most studies so far
have used rats and that it's still
undergoing human trials not only that
but it will involve right now purchasing
a drug from an unregulated online source
and then injecting it into yourself
which is always inherently risky do your
own research proceed with caution and at
your own risk don't come crying to me if
you turn into the lizard this is
actually one of several such miracle
peptides another one is TB 500 which
this time is a synthetic version of TB
for thymosin
beta 4 which is naturally produced in
the thymus gland it's able to up
regulate such cell building proteins as
actin which aids with cell
multiplication and migration along with
wound sealing in the future and with
more studies these drugs may be
available over the counter or on
prescription more exciting still are the
future transhuman techniques that could
one day lead to limb regeneration this
approach currently focuses on a number
of specific genes including Lyn 28 Lyn
28 is a gene that's active in the womb
but dormant during adulthood in most
mammals when the gene is turned back on
in mice they developed the ability to
heal puncture wounds in record time and
even grow lost toes that did also cause
the mice to grow unusually large and
hairy the gene appears to work by
regulating the self-renewal of stem
cells and accelerating the metabolic
rate drugs might also be able to mimic
these effects without the need for gene
modification and future
likewise when the gene p21 is turned off
it appears to enable appendage
regeneration in mice and healing without
scarring and of course there are
countless other fascinating areas being
looked at
right now including the WMT signaling
pathway using fracture repair and
embryonic development
stem cell treatments and more what's
interesting about all this is that it
appears that humans actually already
have the dormant ability to regenerate
limbs and heal wounds more quickly and
many of them use the same pathways that
responsible for growth and repair in the
womb the question you might ask at this
point then is why does it turn off the
answer may simply be that in the wild
the sheer amount of energy required to
regenerate a limb wouldn't be worth the
ultimate gain that's to say that
attempting to regrow a limb might have
been a death sentence for prehistoric
man
whereas living with just one arm
wouldn't be the end of the world
thus natural selection saw that we lost
the ability today we live in much safer
and more plentiful times and so it's
likely in a matter of time until new
treatments become available or until
future transhumans are granted the
ability to permanently regenerate lost
limbs creating real-life Deadpool's
and then we can all be a whole lot more
reckless which is a good thing so you go
guys that's a ton of information on
healing for you to get stuck into I hope
you found some of it useful and
interesting and let me know in the
comments down below what I've missed
there's tons more on this subject to
talk about and I'm definitely gonna be
covering more in future videos I'll also
be looking into lots of other areas of
recovery and healing such as self
myofascial release how to enhance sleep
cryotherapy and more so if that sounds
good then there please subscribe and
I'll also be covering lots more of the
usual stuff soon on fitness training
bodybuilding productivity working online
I've got my home Batcave video coming
along soon so if that all sounds good
then thanks a ton for watching and I'll
see you next time bye for now
I've done it Optimus Primal Scream yes
skylynx and this time no force in the
universe can stop me
[Music]